oh
je
les bombardiers alliés n'a seconde
guerre mondiale a vu l'avènement du
bombardier dans un premier temps ce sont
les allemands qui dominèrent par
l'emploi d'une tactique de support des
troupes au sol lors de leur avancée puis
ce fut le tour des alliés il s'appuie
hier tout d'abord sur les doctrines
allemand de bombardements tactique puis
s'orientèrent vers le bombardement
stratégique tel qu'il avait été
prophétisé dès les années 30
en 1944 les bombardiers tactiques alliés
contrôler les champs de bataille
terrestre tandis que les bombardiers
stratégiques voler jour et nuit pour
pulvériser le coeur de l'allemagne du
japon et leur potentiel guerrier
finalement les bombardiers américains
larguèrent les bombes atomiques sur
hiroshima et nagasaki mettant le japon à
genoux nous ouvrons une nouvelle ère
stratégie
c'est au début de la deuxième guerre
mondiale qu on s'aperçut que l' attaque
au sol pouvait jouer un rôle vital dans
le conflit en résultat le vol qui
vengeance le premier avion ali
spécifiquement conçues comme bombardiers
en piqué pour les champs de batailles
terrestres
1931 vengeance sur construit en cas de
variantes principal à cinq différents
armements et des moteurs de plus en plus
puissants pour une vitesse maximum de
450 kilomètres
cet appareil était le fruit d'une
demande anglaise en 1940 et l'avion vole
à dès 1941
cependant lorsqu'il entend en service en
1943 le vengeance était déjà dépassée
au moins six escadrons de weert
opérationnel sur le type tous prenant
part aux opérations contre les japonais
en birmanie
quatre de ces escadrons étaient anglais
de indien l'un d'eux le square de nejc
opère à partir des aérodromes de johary
et mamour
le vengeance était un avion biplace le
pilote contrôle et une batterie de
quatre à six mitrailleuses fixe dans les
ailes pour le trafic en dépit de sa
taille le vengeance avait une bonne
manoeuvrabilité
les aérofreins sous l'intrados de ses
ailes étaient efficaces
le vengeance vous vous délivrer son
armement avec une très grande précision
avant d'effectuer sa ressource et de
remonter à l'aide du puissant moteur en
étoile
à l'arrière du cockpit le second
d'hommes d'équipage disposer d'une seule
arme d'autodéfense généralement une
mitrailleuses de 12 7
les premières versions est équipé d'une
paire de mitrailleuses de 7 mm 62 à la
place
le vengeance emporté 900 kilos de bombes
l'ancien au piquet avec les aérofreins
déployée pour contrôler la vitesse
la majorité ces avions furent tempe et
dans le rôle important mais bien moins
glamour remorqueur du cil en australie
en angleterre ou aux états unis dans
l'aviation américaine le vengeance était
désigné à 35
au commencement de la seconde guerre
mondiale les rescapés des 176 bombardier
moigne un monomoteur vigueur wellesley
était déjà dépassée mais surtout engagée
contre les italiens en afrique en 1940
et 1941
les bombes étaient emportées dans des
potes profiler sous les ailes
l'armement comporter des mitrailleuses
de 7,7 dans l'elf droite tirant vers
l'avant et une liqueur ce cas mobile
dans le cockpit arrière
après 1941 les wiseler ferreux les gars
de modeste mission de reconnaissance
maritime
issue d'une spécification du 1931 pour
un avion multirôle de transport et de
bombardements le bristol bombay était
comme bien d'autres avions anglais perry
mais lorsque les 50 premiers avions
entrée en service en 1939
monoplan à l hôte assez disgracieux avec
un train d'atterrissage fixé deux
moteurs en étoile ils pouvaient emporter
24 solde en cabine et environ une tonne
de bombes sur le fuselage
avec relativement peu de puissance un
train d'atterrissage fixe et une
aérodynamique assez peu soignés le bombé
ne serait pas vraiment de haute
performance
mais l'appareil ne posait aucun problème
à ses pilotes et la combinaison de volée
d'une à l'épaisse permettait des
atterrissages et décollages très courts
à vitesse très réduit
du coup le bombay pouvaient utiliser des
pistes sommaires sans souci et ce fut
particulièrement précieux en afrique du
nord
les bambins ont servi sur le théâtre
d'opérations méditerranéen
principalement comme transports ils
furent occasionnellement utilisé pour
des bombardements nocturnes contre les
italiens en 1940
le armstong whitworth wheatley poète
emporté trois tonnes de bombes grâce à
la puissance de ses deux moteurs il
constitue à l'ossature du bangor
commandes jusqu'en 1941 lorsqu'ils
furent relégués à une importante
carrière secondaire dans la
reconnaissance maritime l'entraînement
des troupes aéroportées
on attendait beaucoup du bristol
beinheim lequel fut le premier
homardiers tactique à grande vitesse
anglais à son entrée en service en 1937
vous
le blé danemark à importer 5 100 kilos
de bombes et atteignit 450 km heure avec
ses deux bristol mercury en des toiles
de 840 cheveux
la production du mark 1 n avec son
cocktail singulier totalise à 1427
exemplaires construits en angleterre
mais aussi sous licence en finlande et
en yougoslavie
mais en 1939 la plupart avaient été
relégués sur le théâtre méditerranéen
le marque un fish suivi par 3285
exemplaire dublin danemark 4 on est plus
long et plus conventionnel
en dépit de ces moteurs bien plus
puissant il avait de plus mauvaise
performance que son prédécesseur mais
disposer d'un meilleur armements
défensifs ainsi que d'une meilleure
maniabilité en l'air
mais les opérations menées deux jours au
début de la guerre ont montré deux
choses l'une était que ce bombardier les
j'ai manqué de vitesse pour échapper aux
chasseurs allemands l'autre qu'il était
trop faiblement blindés protéger en
faire face à ses ennemis
945 glenmark 5 surdéveloppée pour la
haute altitude mais ils furent très peu
employée
le blenheim fut également le premier
chasseur de nuit britannique efficace
les conversions marque un f et mark iv f
avait un radar d'emmener les premiers au
monde et une gondole ventrale de quatre
mitrailleuses brown et
en dépit de ces limitations et des
pertes
le blé nam chute important car il permet
la formation d'un noyau dur d'équipage
expérimenté dans le bombardement
tactique et l'appui feu
le premier appareil américain entre en
service pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale fut le lanchid rate ce qui
était un dérivé militaire du modèle 14
super elektra de transport civil
il rendit d'innombrables services comme
bombardier léger avion de reconnaissance
maritime à partir du début de la guerre
mais il fut rapidement considéré comme
insuffisant pour ce rôle
en 1940 les anglais demandé à lockheed
de lui donner un successeur une
évolution du modèle 18 l'autre star
civile également appelé vingt tours
ensuite dans les rails
le vin tour avait une soute avons plus
volumineuse capable d'emporter plus
d'une tonne de bombes contre 500 kg pour
le cas de sony
le 28 à marca commença sa carrière avec
le band leurs commandes en octobre 1942
il avait deux fratries neher 2800
étoiles développement 1850 chevaux
chaque puissance qui fut porté à 2000
chevaux avec le vin turin mark ii pour
une vitesse de 480 km
le ventura disposer d'un armement
défensive beaucoup plus important que le
hudson avec deux mitrailleuses 7,62 en
position ventrale 2 à 4 du même calibre
dans une tourelle dorsale et quatre
armes dans le nez
ces derniers comporter deux
mitrailleuses de 12,7 fixes et 2 7 62
mobile
le acer force utilisait également cet
avion comme le b 34 lexington pour les
patrouilles côtières et l'entraînement
les snle employant un grand nombre de pv
avec un est plein équipée de cinq
mitrailleuses lourdes comme bombardier
patrouilleurs
le 28e ne connut pas de grands succès
dans le rôle de bombardier est en fait
ces équipages d'après si bien peu à
l'automne 1943 et 28 raf est réattribué
coastal commandes de squadron servir
essentiellement pour la reconnaissance
météo
cette séquence est typique des rades
deux jours des bombardiers léger du
deuxième groupe du band leur commande en
seulement 3 squadron du groupe numéro 2
basé en angleterre firent opérationnel
sur 20 tirs à l'un d'eux fut le 464 spa
drones basés à métro haute dans le
norfolk
le 16 mai 12 un tueur a pu relancer dans
un raid contre l'un euros drôme de
morlaix en bretagne à leur base de
chasseurs allemands
en dépit de bonnes conditions pour le
bombardement mais d'altitude le raid
obtint pas de résultats significatifs
les équipages spécialement limite
railleur ne pouvait relâcher leur
vigilance en cas de représailles de la
part de la chasse et les douze appareils
roberte indemnes à leur base
2475 exemplaire du vin turin fut
reconstruit au total ils furent utilisés
également par l'australie le canada et
la nouvelle-zélande
bien que les bombardiers lourds pouvait
emporter une grande quantité de bombes
optimisé pour un grand pouvoir de
destruction des avions plus petits se
cantonner au bond simple de 250 500 ou
1000 livres de telles armes avaient un
effet de souffle et de fragmentation et
pouvait être largué avec une plus grande
précision qu'elle est bon plus lourde
le north american mitchell fut l'un des
plus importants avions d'attaqué
bombardier moyens employés par les
alliés pendant le conflit
9816 surproduit toutes versions
confondues jusqu'au b25 j de l' us army
air force les mitchell furent utilisés
sur tous les théâtres d'opérations par
de nombreuses nations comme l'australie
le brésil la france les pays-bas
l'angleterre les usa et même l'urss qui
reçu plus de 860 de ses avions au titre
du programme lend lease
le mitchell est issu du prototype n à 40
financée en propre par north american et
qui fut commandée directement sur plan
en septembre 1939
les premiers modèles de série avait un
fuselage plus large un équipage 5 au
moule de 3 et un armement défensive plus
important les quatre premiers modèles
sur les baies 25
dgh et j les b 25 des du beurre commande
ici en service avec l'escouade en 98 et
180 basée dans le norfolk début 43 avait
été dénommée mitchell marque 2 suivis
par les baies 25j ou michele mark iii
tout au long de la production la
puissance un quart des parler de wright
r 2 600 en étoile 2007 100 chevaux ici
en cours d'entretien en sicile en outre
43 resta inchangé mais les capacités
offensive comme défensive furent
régulièrement augmenté
le p 25 des avec son éviterez emporté
1500 kilos de bombes et 5 mitrailleuse
12,7 au total dans le nez dorsale et
ventrale ils pouvaient atteindre 450
kilomètres heure
le b 25 j ai été limité à seulement 4
140 kilomètres heure mais il était un
formidable avions de combat avec jusqu'à
2000 kilos de bombes et pas moins de
quatorze mitrailleuses 12 7
pour les missions d'attaqué au sol 8
mitrailleuse six étaient installés dans
le nez plein dubé 25 j y en avait six de
plus dans une tourelle dorsale une
tourelle de queue et des nacelles
latéral
en mission de bombardement ou en attaque
en basse altitude le mitchell fut un
avion impressionnant
le tue paul fsb deux fils ont baptême du
feu lors de la guerre civile en espagne
et il devint le principal bombardier
léger soviétique jusqu'en 1943 il resta
toutefois en service jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre mais furent relégués
progressivement à des missions d'attac
deux jours à des missions de
bombardement de nuit pour finir comme
remorqueurs de cible ou dévolu à
d'autres missions de second plan comme
l'entraînement
le sb2 était parfois équipé de skis pour
continuer ses missions pendant le
terrible hiver russe
les deux principales versions disposer
du moteur aim sens ensuite ce fut le sb2
bis améliorée avec des moteurs m 103
bien que techniquement dépassée et
lorsque sa production c'est ça à l'ami
41 le sb2 avaient des performances qui
le rendait encore utiles
sont importantes surfaces à l'air lui
autoriser un plafond très élevé et en
faisait une cible difficile à
intercepter pour les chasseurs allemands
de plus le sb2 possédait un taux de
montée qui permettait à ses équipages de
surprendre les chasseurs qui tentaient
de les engager
alors que l'armement défensif l'usb 2
était très léger grâce à son agilité ce
t'avions à jouer de bien mauvais tour à
la chasse de la luftwaffe la chine la
bulgarie et la finlande furent les
autres utilisateurs du sb29 6967
exemplaires furent produits
les origines du bombardier léger quadri
place baltimore sont liées au x à 22
produit par là même fier et rejeté par
l'uefa remis à copse en 1939 mais
adoptée par la france en tant que martin
160 7 f est repris par les anglais sur
le nom de marie landes bombardier de
reconnaissance
le mari landes utilisé sur le théâtre
méditerranéen à partir d'octobre 1940 je
suis très apprécié dans un premier temps
avant de montrer ses limites
les anglais commandèrent à baltimore
amélioré avec ses deux wright 2006 en
double cyclone en étoile d'une puissance
de 1000 660 chevaux ce qui lui
permettait une vitesse maximum de 480 km
heure elle a placé quatre cent cinquante
du marais landes alors que la charge de
bombes demeurait de 1000 kilos environ
l'armement défensive du nouvel appareil
passé de six mitrailleuses 7 62 pour le
mari landes à entre huit et 14 du même
calibre sur le baltimore mark iii
ce dernier disposait d'une tourelle
motorisés à la place des mitrailleuses
manuel des autres versions
ces nouvelles armes étaient agencés de
la manière suivante 4 dans les ailes 2
ou 4 en tourelle dorsale de en position
ventrale et en option
quatre mitrailleuses fixe qui rend vers
l'arrière
le fuselage du baltimore a été conçue
suffisamment large pour que les membres
d'équipage puis changer de place ce qui
était impossible dans le maryland
1575 baltimore furent construits et bien
qu'il fut employée par l'australie la
france la grèce l'italie l'afrique du
sud et la turquie c'est avec les anglais
qu'il fût majoritairement service le
baltimore s'avéra particulièrement
apprécié par ses équipages même si sa
charge de bombes étaient assez réduit
les premières versions firent un travail
remarquable lors des campagnes du désert
nord africain et en tunisie où les
baltimore attaquèrent sans relâche et
trouver allemande et italienne eder a
dévasté la flotte de navires de lacq qui
ravitaillait l'afrique du nord
les baltimore servir dans huit squadron
anglais et trois sud africains sur le
théâtre méditerranéen et jouèrent un
rôle important sicile à l'instar de ce
bombardement preda drano
il fut engagé en première ligne lors de
la conquête de l'italie parfois même en
mitraillant des cibles juste devant les
pros vous alliez à et ses mitrailleuses
d'elle sa vitesse en ferait elle
apparaît difficile à descendre et son
importante armements défensifs étaient
une autre raison pour laquelle les
pilotes de chasse allemand n'était pas
bien chaud pour l'engager
il fut employé par les italiens au
dessus des balkans après armistice
surnommé le faiseur de veuves raison de
nombreux accidents au décollage ou à
l'atterrissage à cause de son importante
charge à l'air le b26 maraudeur fut
plusieurs fois à deux doigts de voir sa
production interrompue cependant une
fois ces défauts identifiés
le maraudeur obtint le plus bas taux de
perte de tous les bombardiers moyens us
les variantes les plus importantes
furent les b 26 p et c'est assez
semblable et lés p 26 f et g largement
amélioré le b 26 g disposait de pas
moins de onze mitrailleuses de 12 7 on
trouvait une mitrailleuse manuel dans le
nez et dans les postes de tir latéraux
une tourelle double dorsale motorisés et
une tourelle de que auquel s'ajoutent 4
au premier trail 11 plaqués contre
l'avant du fuselage qui rend vers
l'avant pour augmenter la puissance de
feu lors d'un ce trafic
le b 26 disposait de deux pratt &
whitney r 2800 en étoile de 2000 chevaux
le front du vitesse de 450 kilomètres
heure la charge utile était de 2 tonnes
de bombes employés en grande quantité le
maraudeur s'avéra particulièrement
dévastateurs
plus de 5000 exemplaires furent
construits la plupart étant affecté a
lieu à charmer air force
le wellington entre en service en 1938
comme bombardier moyens sa charge utile
de 3 tonnes étant assez remarquable
mais heureusement il connu de lourdes
pertes lors des premiers raids de jours
tout en gagnant la réputation de bien
supporter les dommages dus aux combats
c'est le résultat de la structure de
l'appareil de type géodétique
expérimenté sur le monomoteur ouellet
à partir de décembre bien 139 le
wellington devait à bombardier nocturne
les deux versions importante sur les
wellington mark 1 et marc dit
le mark 1 et est équipé des bristols
pegasus de 1000 chevaux il connu trois
versions dont le mark 1 s'est construit
à 2685 exemplaires
le marque 10 jeux le plus produit
atteignant 3803 exemplaires ils étaient
équipés des brestois hercules 2006 175
chevaux
le wellington était conçu pour un
équipage de six hommes comprenant le
pilote le copilote l'opérateur radio qui
était aussi mitrailleur le navigateur
qui prenait également à la fonction de
bombardier et 2 mitrailleur
lorsque la situation le permettait il
faut noter qu'elle est wellington volet
souvent avec seulement un équipage de
saint côme
toutes les mitrailleuses et est du
calibre 7 7 latourelle données de ces
deux mitrailleuses ainsi que la tourelle
de que équipé de deux ou quatre armes
était motorisé les armes libre était
sous la responsabilité de celui qui
pouvait alors concentrer son attention
sur la plus importante menace en octobre
1943 le wellington fut retirée des
unités du beurre commandes en faveur de
quadrimoteur plus efficace mais sur le
fonds méditerranéen
il devait jouer un rôle important sur ce
théâtre d'opération où les distances à
parcourir était plus court et les
défenses allemandes moins denses la
campagne d'italie vide importante
mission de wellington comme bombarder
moyens ici ce sont des wellington marque
10 basée à amendola au sud de l'italie
en mars 1944
le wellington resta opérationnel dans
cette zone jusqu'en mars 1945 bien moins
connu que les avions tels le de
havilland mosquito ou le junker 88 le
douglas modèle cette fille son premier
vol en août 1939 et la première commande
fut fait par la france pour le modèle
db7 bombardier deux jours
la plupart des appareils n'étaient pas
encore livré au moment de l'armistice de
1940 ils furent alors livré la rs qui
les aplats boston les américains
commandèrent leurs propres versions
comme le à 20 havok
comme le mitchell et le maraudeur le
douglas était un monoplan à l hôte doté
d'un train tricycle et de deux moteurs
en étoile en l'occurrence des rails
cyclone chacun d'une puissance d'environ
1500 chevaux la famille boston havok a
connu une infinité désignation
le plus largement utilisé fut le à 20 c
ici sous la forme d'un poster mark iv de
la rff avec des moteurs de 1600 chevaux
pour une vitesse de 550 kilomètres heure
il avait un armement de 1200 kilos de
bombes et 5 mitrailleuses il avait de
12,7 fixe de chaque côté du nez et une
du même calibre mobiles en position
dorsale et trois autres pouvant tirer
vers l'arrière
la version qui connut la plus large
production fut le à 20 g avec 2850
exemplaire utilisé seulement par l'uefa
mais air force ses performances son
pilotage facile et sa solidité le
permira développement qui conduit à la
fabrication de pas moins de 7400 78
appareils le bombardier douglas fut
utilisée par l'australie le canada et
l'urss qui modifia ses avions avec un
armement dans le nez différents rôles
attaque au sol il veut également utilisé
par les français libres et rien à mieux
montrer ses capacités de grande vitesse
basse altitude que leur mission contre
la france occupée par les nazis
les nazis sont entrés dans cette guerre
avec l'illusion enfantine qu'ils
allaient bombarder le monde entier mais
que personne ne l'ait bombarderait eux
à rotterdam à londres à varsovie et dans
une cinquantaine d'autres endroits ils
ont mis leurs théories naïve en pratique
ils ont semé le vent et maintenant ils
vont récolter la tempête
nous ne pouvons pas envoyer un millier
de bombardier à coup sûr sur l'allemagne
et à chaque raid
pas encore en tout cas mais les temps
viendront nous le pourrons
et nous montrerons nazis qu'ils ne
doivent pas quitter d'un oeil la ligne
d'horizon occidental
ils y verront un nuage aujourd'hui pas
plus large que la main d'un homme
est derrière ce nuage se profile toute
la puissance massive des états unis
d'amérique
quand la tempête éclatera sur
l'allemagne ils se souviendront des
jours heureux à lübeck à rostov wa
colonies
et comme un homme pris dans un ouragan
se souvient des brises légères de l'été
précédent il faudra peut-être un an ou
deux ans
mais pour les nazis l'avenir est écuyer
d'affiché
c'est leur affaire
le remède est entre leurs mains
beaucoup prétendent que l'on peut pas
gagner la guerre avec des bombardements
aériens
eh bien je leur réponds que nous n'avons
encore jamais essayé et nous verrons
l'allemagne qui ne cessent de semer la
mort à travers ses conquêtes
et qui cherche à les étendre encore
sera le terrain d'une première
expérience des plus intéressants
le japon lui servira de confirmation
en quelques mots les chiches marchal sur
arthur harris commandant en chef du
beurre commandes a résumé sans ambages
caractère rationnel de la campagne de
bombardements stratégie contre
le short stirling jeu le premier
quadrimoteur bombardier nocturne de la
ras il entra en service en 1940 mais fut
loin d'être un succès dans ce rôle de
bombardier en raison de son aile petit
et lourdement chargé
c'est les résultats d'une exigence
officielle qui voulait que le stirling
soit capable d'entrer dans les hangars
anglais dont l'ouverture de la porte est
de 100 pieds maximum le stirling de ma
plus tard anna dispensable transporteurs
et remorqueurs de planeur l'avro
manchester est entré en service en
novembre 1940 bien que potentiellement à
bombardier efficace il échoit en raison
du manque de fiabilité de ces rolls
royce venture
en dépit de ses imperfections la
puissance des quadrimoteur alliés
commençait à se faire sentir
le pi la force de bombardements de l'esa
remis air force en europe fut le boeing
b 17 flying fortress qui fut produit à
12 1721 exemplaires
construits avant la guerre cet avion
était prévu pour des bombardements du
joug de précision à haute altitude avec
l'aide du viseur norden voici un b 17 f
qui fut produit avec 3400 cinq
exemplaires avec des moteurs right here
1820 étoiles de 1200 chevaux
la défense du bombardier consistait
principalement dans ses mitrailleuses
qui comptait une 7,7 dans le nez une
douce elle dans une trappe du poste de
l'opérateur radio et une dans chaque
poste latéral ainsi que deux doucet dans
la tourelle de que autant dans la
tourelle ventrale et la dorsale
la charge maximum de bons 2010 était de
8 tonnes en soute et des points d'apport
rarement utilisé permettait de monter à
un machine précis permettait aux
équipages de s'assurer du pourquoi du
comment et bien sûr de la localisation
du timing et de la composition de chaque
mission
le b 17 aces au vernis qui pages de nos
folles comprenant le pilote le couple le
bombardier le radio 5 mitrailleur pour
les tourelles ventrale dorsale et les
postes de latéraux
le mitrailleur de queue était tout seul
isolé à l'arrière
une fois en l'air les forteresses
volantes se rassembler en formation
serrée formant des boxes en trois
dimensions ok chaque formation se
couvrent mutuellement contre les
attaques des chasseurs allemands
mais à l'expérience des combats on
découvrit que les formations en boxe
étaient insuffisantes face aux attaques
détermine d'un luftwaffe et on escorta
les bombardiers avec des chasseurs comme
le p 38 lightning le b 47 ans de bolt
est finalement le plus efficace le p 51
mustang
au sein de leur formation serrée les
forteresses volantes entamèrent la
campagne de bombardements de l'allemagne
contre les sites industriels les moyens
de transport et de communication
cherchant à les détruire par un
bombardement précis
les vagues de bombardier chemin faisant
était assailli par les chasseurs
allemands et devait éviter les
principales zones de flacq rejoindre
leurs cibles et les bombarder
inévitablement il y avait des pertes
face à la chasse à la retirer entier
relief et de nombreux appareils furent
endommagés mais en 1944 1945 et b17 de
la 8ème air force frappèrent de façon
décisive l'allemagne
après avoir complété la mission les
forteresses volantes retournés à leur
base en angleterre les équipages
pouvaient alors se reposer tandis que
les équipes de maintenance s'occuper de
près par les avions dans les prochaines
missions
comme les américains les anglais croyait
dans l'importance des briefings des
équipages cette fois pour un raid en
juin 1942
la toux sèche les tags
favoris de
pages
web
l'équivalent anglais du v10 est furieux
avro lancaster un bombardier de nuit
conçu pour les bombardements de
saturation bien plus que pour les
attaques précises
sur ces images les équipes au sol
complète la préparation de leurs
lancaster la charge en bombe atteignait
8 tonnes dont l'émission de saturation
de volumineuses et lourdement pouvait
être employés
la déflagration de l'énorme charge
d'explosifs de ses armes avec un effet
de souffle terriblement destructeur
les lancaster sont entrés en service à
la fin de 1941 avec des moteurs rolls
royce merlin vingt deux mille quatre
cent soixante chevaux
le lancaster ne connut pas beaucoup de
modifications sous forêts moteur un peu
plus glissant et quelques petits détails
tout au long de la période de production
des 7377 exemplaires
il était défendu par une mitrailleuse de
7,62 situé par 2 dans les tourelles
avant et dorsales et quatre dans la
tourelle de que comme les bombardiers
américains les lancaster avait affronté
l'as des as et la chasse allemande sur
tous les chasseurs de nuit équipés de
radars
mais quand ils atteignent leur cible
comme ici avec le 463 squadron au dessus
de breivik en 1944 les effets du
bombardement pouvait être effrayant
vague après vague les bombardiers tenter
de toucher la même zone et lorsqu ils
réussissaient il créait une véritable
tempête de flamme particulièrement
dévastatrice
les effectuera également quelques
missions à base altitude comme celle
contre l' usine nommée rhône à limoges
par le wing commandeur launcher
lors de la seconde moitié de 1944 le
manque de pilotes expérimentés et de
carburant avait fait de la lutte face
l'aune de ce qu'elle avait été et ce fut
une bonne opportunité pour le bauer
commandes d'enfoncer le clou
lors de la campagne de bombardements
nocturnes le lancaster père avait ramené
paige halifax dont les formes plus
étroites différer les formes arrondies
de lancaster
des bombardements plus précis était
réalisable deux jours
il devenait possible aux anglais de s'en
prendre à des cibles plus petites comme
les centres de communications et les
centres de production de carburants
synthétiques
les allemands firent d'énormes efforts
pour cacher ses cibles clés en faisant
des écrans de fumée à la proche de
bombardier comme lors de cette attaque
de 617e squad rush avec les banques
géantes all boys contre le cuirassé
tirpitz bloqués dans les eaux
norvégiennes
l' usage d'écran fume et est inutile
puisque les anglais pouvaient utiliser
des radars et des systèmes de navigation
efficace contre les cibles invisible
en mai 1943 des missions de bombardement
de précisions ferland s'est directement
contre les barrages de la ruhr tel le
barrage de la sorte vu ici depuis un
mosquito d'escort
bien que ce barrage n'est pas et qui dit
will ceux de leader de la mode le fur
avec des résultats spectaculaires
à l'automne 1945 les attaques de jouer
des nuits contre les villes allemandes
les centres industriels les raffineries
avait vendu les allemands incapable de
résister face aux troupes alliées
en dépit des quantités astronomiques de
bond qui pleuvaient sur l'ennemi et
bombardier vous devez toujours faire
face aux canons anti aériens allemands
qui utilisaient de plus en plus de
radars ce qui améliorerait leur
précision mais bombardier était en train
de gagner
l'un des appareils les plus polyvalents
d'un inventaire américain de cette
période était le b 24 liberator
la production de cet appareil magnifique
plus de 18000 482 appareils le total le
plus élevé de tous les avions américains
des popes le libérateur disposer d'un
train tricycle et se monteraient à la
fois efficace et populaire auprès des
équipages comme on peut le constater
avec les nombres noz à qui
personnalisait ses avions
l'appareil était fiable efficace et au
combat il prouva qu'il était capable de
bien résister aux attaques de la chasse
ennemis
en l'air cl très efficace supporter 4
pratt & whitney tout est noir de 1200
chevaux ce qui donnait une vitesse de
480 km heure
son autonomie pouvait atteint 4500 km
sur les premières versions en limitant
délibérément la charge de bombes à 4000
kg
le long rayon d'action fille du
libérateur un appareil bien plus adapté
aux opérations dans le pacifique que le
b 17 mai le libérateur fut largement en
pays aussi sur le théâtre européen comme
bombardier ou patrouilleur maritime
l'armement défensif était typiquement
américain est constitué de dix
mitrailleuses lourdes de 12,7 elles
étaient disposées par paire dans les
tourelles dorsale ventrale et de que
ainsi que deux en position latérale et
deux autres dans le nez
ces derniers étaient orientés
manuellement l'intérieur d'une et vitré
mais plus tard on les installe dans une
tourelle à partir du b 24 h
la seule autre nation a fait un large
usage du libérateur fut l'angleterre qui
dispose à des versions de bombardements
et de patrouille maritime
comme les autres bombardiers lourds les
libérateurs couvert sévèrement endommagé
mais parvenir à regagner la base
comme cet avion le montre lors d'un
atterrissage d'urgence avec la roulette
de nez rentrer sa faible garde au sol
pouvait s'avérer être un avantage dans
certaines circonstances
le b 29 super forteresse a été conçu
pour prendre le relais des b17 flying
fortress équipages étaient installés
dans un fuselage pressurisés et les
quatre wright cyclone turbocompressé de
2 mille deux cents chevaux pouvait
entraîner ce bombardier puissants
jusqu'à 570 km heure est monté à 33 1600
pieds soit environ 10000 mètres
à ses performances il faut ajouter une
autonomie de 5200 km et une charge de
bond 10 tonnes environ
ramenée pour les missions à long rayon
d'action à environ 6 tonnes la cible
désignée pour cette puissante machine
était le japon après des débuts discrets
à pâtir des bâches chinoise en juin 44
la campagne se déplace à au départ d
énormes l'aérodrome des îles mariannes
avec un effort principal portait sur la
construction et la maintenance de 5
grandes bases sur les trois îles des
mariannes le reste du travail était
limite au soutien essentiel des
bombardes et des équipages des 21e et
plus tard 20e bombers commandes les
briefings n'était pas seulement
important pour s'assurer que les
équipages soit informé non seulement du
camp et du comment de leur mission mais
aussi du pourquoi pour maintenir leur
détermination et leur moral les dangers
auxquels devaient faire face n'était pas
seulement les défenses japonaise des
zones urbaines industrielles au coeur de
l'archipel mais aussi aux l'on survole
maritime pour y aller et parfois en
revenir endommagé les b 29 sont prêts
pour le vol chargé au maximum de
carburant et à la bonne quantité de
bombes les équipages sortent du briefing
sur cette base la piste principale
faisait 60 mètres de large 2800 mètres
de long et disposait de plusieurs
kilomètres de taxiway de route les
taxiways permettaient aux super
forteresse de se déplacer des zones de
maintenance aux zones d'assemblage
proche des extrémités des pistes
principales le réseau de routes
permettait l'accès aux zones de stockage
des bombes et du carburant
organiser une force d'attaqué au sol et
la faire décoller était particulièrement
complexe mais rapidement des procédures
bien établies permis aux super
forteresse de décoller et prendre la
direction des cibles avec le minimum de
gaspillage de carburant
chaque super forteresse avec un équipage
de dix hommes à l'avant du compartiment
pressurisée ont trouvé le pilote et le
copilote dans le nez vitré le bombardier
s'asseyait entre les pilotes le
navigateur assis face à l'avant était
derrière le pilote et un ou deux
mécanicien navigant assis vers l'arrière
était installé derrière le copilote
l'opérateur radio était plus vers
l'arrière dans le compartiment
pressurisée derrière les ailes est
connecté au compartiment avant par un
passage au dessus des 2 soupe de pompe
il y avait deux à trois mitrailleur
chargé de diriger les tourelles le
mitrailleur de que avait à compartiments
indépendants les super forteresse tracer
leur route vers le japon et dévastèrent
ces grandes villes mais également ses
capacités de production militaire en
attaquant l'industrie et les transports
les b 29 entamèrent cette campagne selon
la tactique imaginé pour elle en
effectuant des attaques deux jours à
haute altitude avec des bombes
explosives il s'avéra que en dépit du
viseur perfectionner des bleus 29 la
précision des bombardements étaient très
mauvaises en raison des vents rapide et
turbulent au dessus du japon la campagne
basculant raid à basse altitude de nuit
avec des charges mixte de bombes
explosives et de bombes incendiaires
l'homme qui mis brutalement fin à la
seconde guerre mondiale fut le colonel
paul tibbets en décollant des îles
mariannes au matin du 6 août bien 145
ribette et son équipage à bord du b 29
et ne l'a guère baptisé ainsi en
l'honneur de sa mère larguèrent qu'une
simple bombe atomique sur hiroshima
m
les destructions fut inimaginable il
fallut pourtant le deuxième bombe
atomique sur nagasaki trois jours plus
tard pour démontrer aux japonais que la
guerre était effectivement fini pour eux
les bombardier avait inauguré une
terrifiante nouvelle forme de guerre